HAOHSIANG LIAO:
Our pedagogy here
is we would like to train
our students to become
successful participants
in Chinese culture
by using Mandarin as
their primary language.
So this means we expect
students to behave in a way
that whenever they
have an opportunity
to interact with Chinese
people, they will find
it comfortable from both sides.
So that's the general idea
about our pedagogy here.
In order to do this, besides
language proficiency,
we're talking about the grammar.
We're talking about
the language forms.
We also extend our attention
to their behavioral culture.
And we feel that this is
an essential component
for a successful communication
in a second culture.
The time in class, we'll usually
use it, for the most part,
to provide students the
opportunity to perform.
And by performance, we
mean that performance
in the second culture
based on what we
call the situational knowledge.
So we feel as an
instructor, our role
is to provide a state for
students to practice in class.
I think the example could
be as simple as, how
do you create your teacher
versus your friends
in Chinese culture?
When students ask
me, so what am I
going to learn for
Chinese 101, I always
tell them that
after Chinese 101,
if you have friends who don't
know any Chinese ask you,
so how do you speak
"hi" in Chinese,
your answer can be more
sophisticated than saying
"nihao," which is a general
greeting in Chinese.
So for example, the way we
greet our teachers on campus
is really different from the
way that we greet our friends.
So we're trying to get students'
attention to the environments
or the situation
they're in, for example,
the people they
are speaking with,
their role in the
conversation, or the place.
So speaking with a teacher
takes different strategies
compared to speaking with your
friends in Chinese culture,
for example.
We learn to do things
in foreign languages
so that's a very fundamental
concept here that we're always
trying to convey
to our students.
We try to encourage them
that what you're doing here
is to accomplish things
by using Mandarin
as your primary language.
I think for us, we
consider culture
as common daily practices
and social norms
that define an individual
to function successfully
in a society.
So for us, we feel one of
the priorities as a language
instructor, our
responsibility is
to help students prioritize
those daily practices
and then show them the
patterns or the rules involved.
And once students
have the opportunity
to be exposed to those
rules and then in class,
they have their opportunities to
practice them, to perform them
and as an instructor,
you're providing feedback,
then they go through this
what we call a "cycle."
So out of each class,
they can get out
of each 50-minute
class with a story.
Today's story might be,
how do you decline an offer
from your employer?
Tomorrow's story might be, how
do you deal with conflicts?
So this is what we
call the stories here
and our experience shows
us that a cross-cultural
miscommunication,
for the most part,
they don't lie in
language proficiency.
They lie in cultural competence.
And that's why we would like to
bring the cultural competence
into the core components
of our curriculum here.
We're not saying that language
proficiency is not important.
We're just trying to point
out that the way you behave
in a second culture is
as important as your use
of the language.